Chastity belts aren’t just a terrible contraption
medieval men used to ensure abstinence in
their female partners.
They’re also prevalent in the animal kingdom,
in the form of mating plugs.
The most common use of mating plugs in mammals
like rats, is for a male to ‘fortify’
his female fortress against invasions of foreign
sperm (aka any sperm that isn’t his).
Male rats have a few tricks that serve to
increase the likelihood of their own reproductive
success - even after they’ve had sex with
a female.
When a rat ejaculates, in addition to sperm,
he will deliver an amorphous material with
a very sinister function.
This blobby gel-like plug starts off in liquid
form, and fills a female's’ vagina, blocking
it off to minimize sperm competition from
other males.
Basically, sealing the deal.
As if having your genitals gummed up with
some kind of sticky substance wasn’t enough,
mating plugs can also contain ‘appeasement
substances’, which are chemical cues that
serve to decrease a female's’ sexual receptivity.
In other words, the mating plug works to block
a female from future sexual encounters both
physically and psychologically.
The whole notion of mate plugging seems horribly
unfair to females, and frankly, in a lot of
cases, it is.
However, where there’s a will there’s
a way, and males that have not yet had the
opportunity to mate with a specific (plugged)
female will often work tirelessly to dislodge
her current plug before copulating and then
depositing one of their own.
A female herself may also ‘groom out’
a mating plug by repeatedly licking, chewing,
or consuming it directly.
It IS high in protein after all!
A female that is HAPPY with her sexual partner
may actually be on board with having her vagina
sealed up.
Indeed, females sometimes solicit something
called ‘post-ejaculatory mounting’ from
their male partners - which involves mounting
(not sex) and gives the plug more time to
harden while protecting it from being displaced
by another male.
As the female gives birth the plug is also
pushed out and she is once again free to mate...and
be re-plugged.
Again, and again, and again.